[Applaudissements]
si nous regarde j'ai remis à qui
prennent contact avec moi sur la page
facebook et qui viennent nous voir dans
l'émission j'aimerais bien les invités
voilà dans touche pas vous postez nora
qui se posent pas fait que des blagues
de cul tout le temps j'en fais pas prêts
nous excite déjà c'est pas vrai qu'il ya
un peu mielleuse donc c'est vrai c'est
en boucherie chevaline 2010 et alors là
laurent fontaine l'a tué c'est que sa
part dénoncé me là ils allaient tout
dukurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai moi je vous raconte tout dans cette
émission je vous dis on est alors ils
jean-luc l'oise et à la radio avec moi
sur europe à tous les matins et idem
voir ma taille mais si j'ai un gros
problème avec laurent fontaine il à la
tourette du cul assis à côté de lui où
l'on parle moins
moi je suis au bout du rouleau vraiment
tout quidam boire mais très sérieux j 20
questions et je passe un truc alors vous
êtes mais en fait vous le dire tout du
prix des médicaments mais vraiment il ya
du lourd
il n'était pas bien allez on continue
avec au nom de la vérité alors céda
scripted reality c'est à dire c'est tiré
des histoires vraies et donc des
comédiens book aujourd'hui